pt il videogioco horror che ha fatto
rabbrividire tutta quanta litio ma
secondo voi la sigla pitti per che cosa
sta pista per potato thriller potato
thriller stream e steam ed potato
edition c'è visto che si chiama potato
trilla stime potato edition cela potato
edition di un gioco chiamato potato
thriller ma di che cazzo stava però
potato thriller nel senso che potato è
quel potato da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
avessimo video sono farjane ed oggi
siamo stupiti cioè potato thriller
sarebbe una parodia del vero pt che
sarebbe quel videogioco horror che altro
non ho mai fatto chiedetevi il perché
facciamo story mode visto che mi ha
sempre incuriosito fare questa qualche
bello che poi tra l'altro ed i colori
tuoi storia cioè lega non c'è verso vale
ragazzi in uk ma vi giuro non so che
cosa aspettarmi da sta roba da posto
titolo siamo partiti che bello alla
madonna
sono curioso di vedere che cosa hanno
fatto per paralizzare quel video game
che non ho mai neanche aperto la grafica
è proprio or e melo subito se ce l'hai
con me per carità di dio c'è un problema
in realtà faceva più paura prima che
adesso è meglio non ho capito il perché
salve c'è qualcosa ma sei un pene
fantastico mi è appena esploso il naso
davanti gioco dell'anno meraviglioso
cioè giuro
ok a grazie mi apri quella porta in modo
sensuale
spero che non sia il tizio nel quadro
perché potrebbero essere problemi
permesso è la madonna cos'è belli avrei
detto vini nella mia stato non ho a zio
è stata lei a dirmi di venire dentro
cioè non sai no no no no in quel senso
ce ne se sono entrato perché me la
chiede dove cazzo devo andare sono
uscito non tocco tua moglie non mi
interessa spero che tu non sia al tizio
ma è questa tua moglie questa del quadro
no perché stupenda giuro non ho capito
niente però va bene
a meno che non debba e va bene sembra un
po maurizio costanzo visto la distanza
da the baroni ecco reborn ita de maria
amauri quello sta giocando al in isole
shown in un momento del genere devi
giocare alle isole shaun ma c'è ita chi
si è veramente sexy o fate bollire posso
toccarti io non posso toccarti va bene
giuro che ancora non ho capito cosa ne
sto facendo della mia vita questa è tua
moglie
no perché veramente avrei preferito il
tizio nel quadro a questo punto spengo
la luce perché se sei già messa male a
livello di occhi non vorrei accecanti e
zia
tanto ci pensi già tua esplodere quindi
no problem ragazzi miei il potente o
thriller ma sono chiuse le porte
ok questo è successo mi sono ritrovato
legato a una sedia ma sono io sì sono io
per forza che belle gambe
anche ho intuito lo sapevo che eri tu
brutto deficiente a parlare perché mi
hai sequestrato è va bene fai quello che
vuoi zio cioè non so se sono stato
schiaffeggiato da una patata di mite che
giornata di merda gioco di summer khatib
picchia non vedo l'ora di vedere che
cosa hai creato summer khatib pti potato
thriller o è start quattro ore prima a
questo so io quindi al in buon piantar
specialist sarebbe calciatore di tagli
che dopo la faccia da cacciatore di taiz
sam andando a cercare potato man ha
quindi c'era un motivo sarà in quella
casa
chi è quello dexter robot son sidekick
stiamo andando il children potato man va
bene ma guarda che eroi ralenti cioè mi
chiama è l'effetto sonoro ma cos'è un
elicottero per a quello ma l'effetto
sonoro dell'elicottero era epico o siamo
tornati qualche sarà stanziare la moglie
devo trovare potato man perfetto ma non
l'ha già fatta st parte scusate posso
passare senza intanto esplode lo è lo
sapevo mi spiegate cosa devo fare in
questo gioco a parte andare da una parte
alla salve perché è legato nel bagno
ok è pronto frate farà malissimo dai
borsa scura
non vorrei che entrasse mia moglie in
questo momento non saprei spiegare bene
questa scena tornerò a liberarti zio
stato nessuno può bastarci solarme la
distruzione di massa è la madonna
supertassa porta prima era chiusa
perché sono ritornato qui capitana come
ho fatto a cag armi addosso con una
patata
ma dai ma il tipo al cesso è morto cosa
è morto risucchiato accesso lo sa bene
hai cambiato position ma che cazzo fai
ma ti stai a fa la vasca o è perché i
voli scusa frate giuro che non volevo
controlla che quando entri nessuno io do
un'occhiata davanti tornerò a liberarti
giuro bo si avverta st porta ma come
warning non dovresti andare dietro
questa porta il gioco potrebbe crescere
o andrà in una realtà alternativa va
bene proviamoci
ma lascia il gioco sono convinto sì ma
come si sa per caso trovando senso a
questo videogioco vi prego perché io
veramente sono quasi disperato dopo anni
e anni è cambiata l'ambientazione a
quella di prima solo quei colori diversi
io sto gioco non lo capisco lega cosa
sta succedendo ma spiegatemi ti senti
fortunato va più o meno entra per
vincere una chance di vincere
ricordati soltanto questo codice
scrivetelo 36 1993 36 1993 ok
993 fatto io non ho veramente parole
pronunciate fantasmi cosche videogioco
sto giocando va visti mi date una
spiegazione vi prego vieni qua
deficiente
dai non ci credo ce l'ha fatta bastardi
tanto gesù benedetto spiegami emo quando
abbiamo iniziato sta roba è tutto un
[ __ ] nonsense non si capisce un cazzo
ok zio sea è tornato successo questo ora
di nuovo per tasta porta uomo fantastico
sentiva affanculo te è la realtà
alternativa fammi capire cosa devo fare
della mia vita
vai a dormire devo andare io devo andare
a dormire ragazzi l'importante è andarci
sculettando
dove dovrebbe essere letto spiega ok mi
ha fatto ripartire di qualche palla
basta per l'amor di dio mi squilla il
telefono rispondo giuro che non
rispondono i turn ottobre intel
mi hai cacciato il caso stavo scherzando
va bene se rispondo lo penso anch'io
frate il tizio pensa che io sia una pera
che cosa ne pensi
grazie di aver espresso la sua opinione
comincia una nuova partita skip deraglio
c'è ancora ancora basta basta
sapete che vi dico andate affanculo
andate a mutu e il tuo caso di thriller
delle patate di quello che vuoi o
ragazzi che dire a priori aver giocato
veramente al videogame della vita ho
deciso di non giocare apt a suo tempo
perché ho detto questo gioco non è
abbastanza figo aspettavo che uscisse
potato thriller per dire sì cazzo
finalmente un videogioco fatto bene
concludo qui l'episodio spiegatemi voi
che con anzi non ho spiegato voglio
sapere un cazzo non voglio sapere va
bene così quello che vedo vi sia
piaciuto spero che se vi è piaciuto
videogioco un bel pollicioni su stockel
avete adorato pare stia davanti non
mangiano manco più patate in vita mia
dopo salva sono traumatizzato veramente
traumatizzato però l'assenza di un
efficiente strumento è un mi piace anche
la pagina di facebook cavani vi devo
tornare iscrizioni sono vestiti 16
abbiamo così video eh va beh ricordatevi
che comunque questo probabilmente dal
gioco dell'anno è ancora non ne sono
sicuro però difficilmente troverò
qualcosa che lo batterà marebbe ragazzi